back
damn papa just stop just stay my snap
for you just scam is easy this game is
easy oh look at that
oh look at you whole new world a whole
new world look how easy it is okay I've
said this game is look at this I'm gonna
do some crazy [ __ ] what that wasn't as
crazy as I imagined in my head what
about this then what about this family
[ __ ] okay this game is so easy look at
that
wait how the heck am I gonna get up
there you know what I bet this is super
simple I bet you family this is easier
oh look at that oh no I almost had it
first try baby this game is all about
overcoming your fears look at that look
at that so easy my god this game look at
that easy easy brother yes grab the
[ __ ] hand there you go easy oh my god
oh no what is down there
what is down there no no I can't I can't
go do all that and let me
oh my god what is down there I'm just
gonna check just so I know why we have
to deal with
okay we're safe apparently the game
developer decided not to be an [ __ ]
all the sudden I don't know why but I
think we got to land on that hook over
there
look at that though kemplay has
struggled in this easy game if you
complain that this game is hard you need
to complain at your mama from not look
at that look how easy that wish you need
a complaint of your mama because she
clearly has been cuddling you your whole
life I bet you are still sucking on them
nips I know how to make these now easy
easy easy
I told you disgusting I bet you you
didn't do this on the first try baby
first try yeah I'm shooting man milk out
of my nipples you got a problem with
that talk to my lawyer
wait what the heck is this what the heck
are you do curry No how am I gonna get
across that that's crazy that's way too
high oh I see oh I see oh I think I know
how what I gotta do look at this alright
look at this look at this fam oh look at
that
no no no you got a little scare they
didn't yet I never fought
I have never fallen in my life easy easy
I know wait for ilda how am I gonna do
this it's a it's a wall there where am I
supposed to go down here oh hey look
there's a bunch of other pots here
that's cool
did you ever know that you're a part
where am I going
this is very confusing I don't know
where I'm going I know nobody's knowing
I check out this or five whichever where
the wind is blowing I guess we're going
back boys oh oh oh it's a meatball
everybody I know how to climb meatballs
oh god I'm sliding oh there it is I see
it I see it too long oh no oh no oh God
oh oh
I peed it obey Oh [ __ ] snow they just
had it to add snow in the game butter
and a pooper yeah butter and a pooper
butter in a pooper stupid is my mousepad
okay my mouse pad is too small I have
the smallest [ __ ] mouse pad can
someone please invest in a mouse pad for
me
what I can't like look how tiny it is
look how tiny it is I can't go up and
down on this [ __ ] I did not study
industrial engineering and management
for three [ __ ] years to fail at this
easy ass game okay this is the easiest
game ever made ever made ever made this
is the easiest game ever mayne ever
mayne ever mayne ever made that's right
that's so easy I can do it blindfolded I
can do it blindfolded you want me to do
it blindfolded yeah yeah you want me to
do it you want me to do it you want me
to do it huh you want me to do it a
blindfold a huh you're are you crazy
Oh you come now crazy I'm sexy suck a
dick suck old all the dicks god damnit
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] this game is
garbage this is garbage as game ain't
scared of anything
fearless how can you be so handsome
fearless attractive perfect I know what
you're thinking love is blind
hello mr. meatball we meet again very
good mr. meegar now where is that slimy
oh god he slides
he slides on this meatball you're not
supposed to slide I'm just gonna
investigate where is it okay
just investigating right now of course
this is so anyway look at that so smooth
just math Sabath sass man another one
guardo me guarda me mama mia pizzeria
gorgonzola in my [ __ ]
oh how about that
gotta get Zola got a gunshot for
everybody
everyone gets one little gunshot hurry
up everybody hurry up if you hurry my
little child honey for the Gargan sarna
i know how much you love the gorgonzola
Galligan salad
I panicked it's fine it's fine it's fine
Italy oh my god I cry so funny Hellmuth
this Jam la vista piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh Mamma Mia the meatball ah no oh Jesus
oh my god is that land it's this how
Christopher Columbus felt he was filled
with anger
that's why oh don't say hey in and
across set of lincoln van x ah love
Xiamen yeah hurry about Eddie Cheever ah
bah da whole ah ma come here MA what do
I gotta do now get on that bucket huh
I've seen streamers try and do this
because they ride the snake do not ride
the snake this has to be easy right I'm
not good it's not even a snake
go away snake I am NOT interested no
gone Oh God okay let's not mess around
here oh god it dangles guys it dangles
oh wow that was so hard
people struggle at this [ __ ] honestly go
cry to your mama I am this game okay
you're dangling a bit much for my flavor
stop it stop the tangling stop it look
at that perfect perfect harmony and
balance look at that couldn't be better
than that what what how the hell am I
gonna do that
Epis next episode you will find out now
excuse me thank you leave a like leave a
like for me bus and excuse me cuz I
gotta go
bet you my son trendy